last time on compchomp Cold War
computers were showing real promise at
translating Russian into English
Georgetown University staged a
successful tech demo and the press was
impressed times were good for machine
translation Hey okay now that we're back
the money starts rolling in because if
the public support something politicians
can't lose by throwing money at it but
people started taking sides round one
fight in a this corner you had your
linguistically minded perfectionist they
wanted to feed computers all the
detailed grammatical rules about every
language and in this corner there were
your brute force crowd room for sirs
were all about the evidence you set
computers loose on real sentences and
they should be able to find the patterns
on their own
unfortunately progress from both sides
just wasn't living up to the bold claims
made after Georgetown and the public
they started to notice in 1962 Harper's
ran an article titled the trouble with
translation and with a title like that
you know it was going to be fair and
objective the author recalled a
demonstration of machine translation
where the computer was given the
scriptural nugget the Spirit is willing
but the flesh is weak the output we're
told is laughable the liquor is holding
out all right but the meat has spoiled I
just want to pause for a moment the demo
reported there didn't happen but this
story and Harper's really illustrates
how far machine translation had fallen a
few years earlier those exact same
reporters were just heaping praise on it
and now it was the butt of their
magazine jokes
the scientist stepped in for some damage
control do you remember bar-hillel our
first full time machine translation man
he argued that our expectations were
just unreasonable natural language could
be ambiguous and computers cannot handle
ambiguity we shouldn't expect them to
translate languages for us we should
just get them to help us translate for
ourselves translating languages was way
more complex than even the experts could
have guessed it was literally turning
out to be harder than rocket science
now in the face of souring public
opinion the US government because
again they only like throwing money at
popular things they commissioned the L
pack Josh is that a llama wait no sorry
it's it's not a llama it's actually an
elite group of seven experts tasked with
deciding the usefulness or uselessness
of machine translation and computational
linguistics as a whole that's quite a
task their verdict Oh will we'll get
into that but first there's something
you need to understand throughout the
history of artificial intelligence
people get sold on promises far beyond
their wildest dreams and it happens so
often that there's a term for it the AI
hype cycle and when things go wrong a
chill sets in a chill with lasting
effects it's called an AI winter and no
amount of jackets can protect you from
that chill so the verdict the 1966 AL
pack report concluded that we do not
have useful machine translation and
there is no immediate or predictable
prospect of useful machine translation
ouch computers it turned out we're twice
as expensive as human translators and
they were doing way way worse the
officials were convinced and machine
translation was defunded the first AI
winter set in computers and language
obviously had a rough start but I
promise it gets better
eventually subscribe go eat your borscht
and uh write some code chomping